brought to you by the witcher 3 wild
hunt available now gentlemen Eric hey is
on the couch which means we must be
talking about the Big D the big team
let's talk Americs big honking knee yeah
air take destiny second expansion pack
house of wolves BAM it's happening tell
us all about it yeah I came out today
this morning 10am fallen people have
betrayed the Queen so she's like why
don't you come help me out and kill
these guys I won't give you stuff yeah
who doesn't want to get stuff and be a
guardian one type of stuff uh exotics
legendaries like Annie just hopped in
actually like Reese more recently and we
kind of actually ja sure put him through
a little bit today and he got his first
exotic yeah you got sure but survivors
you're not huh I didn't know him on his
man i know he carried you put the team
on it carry me i'm getting the easy so
you i started back playing destiny like
own like like weeks ago yeah yeah did
you level up just for house of wolves I
was trying I've only gotten to like 27
now mhm um but ok so Tate yes you're
downplaying your hype you were so high
today oh yeah i'm excited i mean like
pain I so look I take it away kidding
from playing destiny cuz i would just
burnt out i played way too much everyone
knows it and I was like I wasn't I was a
little skeptical about dishes because
it's like okay they didn't have a raid
and the raid was kind of like their big
thing yeah but now they have two
different kind of endgame activities
instead one is a pvp more pvp oriented
and one is a PVE one which is the prison
of elders which Annie and I got to play
earlier it's kind of like horde mode
with a twist except there's like
different rooms and different enemies
and there's like objectives that you
have to go through like diffuse of mine
so you know you you and your teammates
it's a group of three now instead of six
unlike a raid yeah you know you guys try
to you know communicate with each other
like we got to get to a and defuse that
and like like Oh be careful though
there's all these monsters trying to
like shoot you to such an Endless mode
as well um it's not endless there's I
think five rounds for the 28
the 32 and the 34 and then there's a 35
version right which has like the big
boss kind of guy um solid tonight got it
yeah pretty much but yeah story was
great too we didn't I didn't get to play
story when i went up to bungee so
getting to see some of this stuff was
cool that jumping puzzle kind of thing
that would just show right there
actually is like really fun yeah you
know it's one of like the more unique
things that happen in destin yes it was
the right stuff when they started like
mixing it all yeah yeah exactly so is
this do you feel like this sort of
punches a bit harder than the dark below
did um yeah I think there's more new
stuff and I think they definitely did a
better job kind of leading up to this
one then they've been actually slowly
getting better with dark below they
added some content that you could play
before the expansion kind of like a WoW
right like you know how like when wow
expansions come out yeah they give me
that big patch like that meaty patch
right before and things start to turn
different ways they did that a little
bit with dark below but they really kind
of did it with house of wolves this time
and basically they're all these like
many events that you could do leading up
to today where you hunted bad guys and
like bad fall and guys which is like
theme with this expansion and that kind
of stuff school like and they gave you
and they gave you some other stuff as
well but that's like kind of the main
point of it um but yeah I think
accessibility wise it's more accessible
than it was originally actually let's
talk about society because you like you
started back two weeks ago like do you
feel like this was somebody that you
need is like power level up to or like
catch up with narrative to or were you
have it easy were you able to like grab
it pretty quick well okay so like this
coming a lot of people play destiny a
lot people hardcore in a destiny that's
it that's undisputable right so I was
like why because we played on the
livestream you were not you were cold on
it yeah Kevin's review is cold on it and
I was like but I remember playing
through the first couple levels on the
Xbox one and really liking the way
controlled granted I don't really play
shooters on console I try not to yeah so
i bought the slime princess on pc
exactly over the MPC as much as i can
but i really was impressed with the
controls on xbox one and i was like wow
the auto aim is beautifully done like
it's so good
and they reward you for that stuff and
getting headshots and stuff the hand
cannon it's like addicting just the way
it shoots it's just so that bungie
quality for shooting like it cannot be
understated also what cannot be
understated is the story is garbage or
not garbage yeah it's just like not
there's nothing there it's like a like
Aaron Samson our guy here yeah it's a
paragraph yeah of a story that's all
they tell you right so like those first
that first playthrough where you go
through all the missions that's nothing
the game hasn't even started which a lot
of people hate that that's the fact
right the game has started right I need
only to make hours and hours I don't
like it as far as a traditional review
like this is maybe one of a problems we
face as a website going forward the
traditional review starts and ends at
that point basically because you gotta
move on the next thing you got to put a
score on it and ship it ship the review
that's when the game starts though they
just they warmed you up they told you
how things work they showed you the
enemies and showed you the places you're
gonna be going back to over and over so
you think that with the green boughs and
you're like oh I'm gonna go do the
mission again oh but there's a boss
battle this time that's like ten times
better than anyone you faced in the game
and you're with your buddies cuz all
them are playing too so you want to get
on it and everything's great and it's
like like I don't know I can't I think
that's I can't really Express like how
much I'm enjoying Destin cuz it's like I
know I'm not supposed to maybe that's
what I'm like feeling guilty about it
like I think you like I'm loving it uh
maybe I shouldn't tell mom dad like you
know I mean and and yeah like this new
stuff they just added today is like a
whole bunch of stuff that likes the
Scrooge McDuck yeah the scrutiny a
diamond is like one of the bigger things
to write like in the past there were
ways that you could kind of get stuff
like loot and like gear and stuff like
that and it was kind of like luck base
gosh right it's like oh I might get
something I might not but here you have
something like this which is the prison
of elders which is a new PBE element
there's four versions and yeah thanks
Josh aw daddy oh and you're there and
you're guaranteed Luke right that big
chest yeah you're guaranteed and exotic
you're guaranteed a weapon so now I got
an exotic asian oh cool and he was
losing it I'm
he's never gone yeah so that's that's
the good part they've there's a bunch of
quality of life stuff that's come
through like since the beginning it's
very different the Destiny phone app is
amazing and I haven't seen a game really
you [ __ ] a phone in five yeah Yello
duty the phone app is revolution oh this
is expected this legit you take it a job
of Bungie what's going on it's dealers
in perspective that was so good cuz I'm
like I'm still trying to make a game
plan of how to level right cuz I'm like
yeah I'm 27 I gotta get cuz the only
many levels like your armor has more
light and then that love ya right its
kind of kind of confusing but it's it's
self-explanatory once you want you in it
hmm I'm like okay so what happens when
you're 32 cuz you guys have 32 and then
they're telling me Oh not only do we
have 132 we have 3 30 tues and I'm like
okay so you guys have done all this
gotten to the end and then done it again
twice so like there isn't so they just
like Gotham again and again and then not
only that only I think only josh has
done three different classes they're
doing the same class really on TV
characters right because there's reasons
for that and like so so the I think it's
like the meat of this game like the
shooting the boss battles the teamwork
the persistence like you're going in
this world dude you're doing all the
stuff and then it's it stays there like
you know it's addicting and so they're
going back doing it again oh now you're
in so I'm in because and this is risking
my procession about shooters is like
okay so woman Stein comes out it's like
I love the way that game works I love
sliding around shooting Nazis and doing
cool stuff but it's like but wait I
don't get anything for it hahaha you get
fun here's the thing I believe it but I
get funded destiny and I get a new gun
and a new armor set and I gotta go hang
on my buddies and shoot a big boss kinda
like so so I hated blood border I don't
hate it but like I don't get those me I
don't play them but this is kind of like
oh these boss battles are cool you got
figuring out their real hard so it's
like kind of like blood board but
shooter I'm having serious flashbacks to
me like at the end of last year and then
it's all gonna go over the camera yeah I
was like I was like running with these
guys like we were rating frequently like
I was all I'd
and have multiple characters but like
playing pretty frequently frequent like
same stuff over and over again the same
stuff like the camaraderie the rewards
like that there there is a peel there
there is obviously the mechanics I think
no one disputes that the like
mechanically that game is stellar I just
interested to see how you feeling like
four weeks when they are not new that is
they throw it out he's probably the next
what happen well that's the question for
Eric as my question is like all right
come back to house of wolves you talked
about a bunch of new stuff and obviously
the new stuff is fun to do literally the
day it comes out but like I don't you
see like in terms of the longevity of
house of wolves vs crota or versus just
the core destiny stuff the do you see
any real difference or anything that so
with crota it lasted longer because what
they did was they time stuff out they
said here's the normal raid you can do
it and I remember the time frame but
it's like you can do it now but you
can't do the hard one for another month
or whatever it was four to six weeks so
basically they kind of spaced you out in
terms of like okay you get at least two
months potentially right because you are
forced yeah behind a lock of you can't
play this with this i said i'm giving
you eighty percent of the expansion and
then giving you being like you can have
the other 20 in a month I don't know how
people didn't lose their [ __ ] about that
the way that people lose their [ __ ]
about DLC for a full game part of it was
you probably might not be at the first
week so maybe it takes you two weeks
anyway so like you're learning and
taking it takes time to pick like
there's different sets of skills for
people right there's like you know your
high-end your hardcore and then you're
like novice or amateur whatever right
and so they go at different paces yet
multiple characters blah blah blah this
was also probably employ to stretch it
out not gonna watch probably distract
you think they need to do that with PES
pose I don't think they can unless they
have stuff that they haven't talked
about I don't think they necessarily
need to but you're satisfied as 1i
player if this is what it protects
though cuz we played how long do we play
this morning we already done with the
story missions yeah so do you think
there's enough content there too like
are you happy as a destiny player
somebody who pumps a lot of hours into
this game with what what's in high
school I am I am happy with it but it's
like for me i'm going to play the crap
out of it this week and with whoever
needs help whatever and then continue to
do it for like probably like a month
like Chris said maybe six weeks ish and
then you know maybe play which on the
side or something for the first time the
next exact come on yeah it's like a wild
thing though right it's everyone's
excited for even though the content is
different than wild content because like
it more heavy or whatever but they're
excited for new content right and
they're excited to do stuff they've
never done before which it is which they
have two new avenues right which cuz
it's like they've never had these things
before and so you play and then you're
going to be like oh this is really fun
play both of them and then you're just
gonna be like okay every two days a week
I'm gonna do it finish and then I'll
play like sodium Peter salsas only Peter
than your back you've also been playing
only like about an hour and a half of
night except for like on sunday i played
a pretty long stretch but like yeah I'm
not bingeing so much which maybe helps
yeah yes I yeah fingers crossed we'll
see what happens if you are still
playing in a month you're still speaking
a month Christine chapter III I'll
[ __ ] get in i'll be playing Eddie
whoa I level up I'll be okay 30 20 if
you're still playing afternoon three
I'll do a full what up 32 what's the top
limit so he just has to get to 32 I
don't play no no no nice of the key so
Peter he's not that far away it's not
that far what like let's just around the
corn so I might I saw it a lot to do
though like if I was already 32 this
one's fast butyl more that be you'll get
there i well know i look at them because
i was forced him to play it okay great
in come on huh all right in the team all
right that's the lobby for this week
you